hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive so it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the consultant editor of the daily mail
andrew pearce and the associate editor
of the daily mirror kevin mcguire really
good to see you both hope you're well
hello looking forward to chatting
through it all between now and midnight
because you're going to be here for all
that time first though let's take a look
at what's on the front pages and the
budget inevitably the financial times
has a comprehensive review of today's
budget with the headline sunac backs
johnson on spending
the eye calls the chancellor a big
spender who has taken the tax burden
back to the 1950s
the times calls it sunax spending spree
so there's a taste of some of the papers
i should say they're coming very late
we'll try and show you the other front
pages as they come in and andrew pierce
and kevin mcguire are here to talk
through them though
and the daily telegraph i'm not sure if
we did see that one actually but it's
got a picture of rishi sunak and boris
johnson andrew uh at the bar uh
cheersing you could say
this budget and the headline is hey big
spenders so what kind of reception from
seeing these front pages which as i say
have coming in very late do you think
this budget's got
well i think they'll they'll be very
pleased with what i've seen so far and
it's it's very difficult for the
telegraph because it still has great
stature instincts it wants fiscal
rectitude it wants tax cuts it doesn't
like huge public spending and it will
hate the fact that now that this chance
of this year has taken more in tax in
one year than at any time since 1993
which was black wednesday and that the
few chances to raise that yield that was
normal lamont who then got the boot and
then ken clark came in and did another
budget so that's a measure of how much
bishi sunak is hitting tory voters all
voters in the pocket with taxes
but
huge increases in public spending which
puts the labour party in huge
difficulties because uh he um that the
spending
he's peppered all sorts of areas from
you know extra money for people to
remove cladding from their from their
blocks of flats to uh billions more for
affordable housing uh it's a very he's
the he's the williest most political
chance of this checker i think the
conservatives have ever had it's a
clever budget in my view but i'm the
thatcher right tory wants to see tax
taxes being cut you can't do that we're
coming out of a pandemic
the economy is recovering much quicker
than we thought unemployment now they
say we'll peak at 5.2 percent i can
remember when we went into this wretched
pandemic there were dire predictions it
could be as high as 11.9 12 so that's
well under half that uh i mean that
unemployment level so i think it's an
incredibly clever budget i think the
telegraph will be struggling really deep
down to support it but they know what's
the alternative well yes and let's take
a look at the guardians take on it kevin
they again this word spend keeps coming
up in the headlines doesn't it sunak's
post covered plans spend now cut taxes
later i mean andrew was saying it's
going to be difficult for labour to
criticize and a lot of people have said
this feels a bit like a labor budget
some people say this could have come out
of the mouths of gordon brown for
example do you agree with that
um elements of it yes and i thought
rachel reeves the shadow chancellor who
had drafted in at the last moment
to reply because it's traditionally the
opposition leader but kia starmer tested
positive with uh covert uh i think she
did a pretty good job with it but
there's no doubt
russia sunak has put uh put his tanks on
labour's lawn and labour's going to have
to work out how to take to
take them down how to explode them and
part the part of it will be that uh the
damage of the last uh 11 years is only
partly repaired for instance money for
skills or it's only about half that's
that's gone all of a sudden money's
coming for so-called family hubs because
the first thousand days of children's
lives are seen as important well why
close all those sure start centers those
children centers more than a thousand
and that what was cut is is far more
than what's been spent and again but
there's there's no doubt yeah i i agree
i think he's very political as a
chancellor he's very gordon brown
in that sense so labor's going to have
to pick it apart
if you look at the front page of the
telegraph spending and they they rather
you know they say it was going back to
1970s level i would never problem with
that actually um uh and i think if we
just saw andrew leaving it's because he
locked himself out of his flat earlier
he's not gonna mention that i wasn't
gonna mention that but if we did
and he's got a locksmith in who i
suspect now wants pain although i think
he's making more sense now and now he's
not there than he ever make when he is
but anyway anyway but if we looked at
that telegraph from page um
they just
report pretty straight spending but the
story below is households fees face to
squeeze from in from inflation and flat
wages inflation could be 4.4 4
household incomes uh over the next five
years are going to be growing by 0.8
percent which is historically very very
low
and he left now he left out his national
insurance increase the 1.25 percent
that's going up so yes it's a clever
budget but it could unravel very quickly
if the focus goes on to his tax risers
rather than the spending and people all
of a sudden feel very hard done to
because their family budgets are being
squeezed and um andrew has just arrived
back in this chair but i'll let him
catch his breath for a moment i was just
having a calamity with my front door he
got locked out so that's the locksmith
he's finally
fixed the lock
fantastic stuff um i will fire a
question at you then cause you look like
you're very composed once again um so a
lot of pictures of the prime minister
and rishi sunak clinking glasses
obviously a reference to the fact that
alcohol duty is coming down but what
about what does this budget tell us
about the relationship between those two
men i mean traditionally there's ten
tension between those two roles but a
lot of people have said that rishi sunak
has had to
give in to the spending instincts of the
prime minister is it boris johnson is
getting his way with this budget do you
think
well that that's what rishi sunat wants
people to think he because he's got an
eye on the main chance he wants to be
prime minister at some point there's no
vacancy at the moment boris johnson's
popularity is still pretty strong
despite even though kevin finds that
hard to to accept
so he wants to worry about benches to
think you know if he was in charge he'd
be trying to cut taxes if he was in
charge perhaps he wouldn't be spending
quite as much money and actually it's
that reckless spencer if you're number
10 who wants all of this but actually i
think they work together quite well we
know in the summer there were real
problems there were real tensions over
um uh it was all there was a leaked
letter all to do with the chaos over
whether we could or couldn't fly in and
out of britain and the chancellor's
letter was leaked the chances people say
it wasn't him it was a letter to to um
to the prime minister you think he could
have just popped next door and had a
conversation about it but um i think the
relationship is is better than people
think now i think they did have a
problem uh and uh
the prime minister knows if he's to be a
success if he's to win the next general
election rishi sooner has to deliver and
so does michael gove who's in charge of
leveling up but michael gove will be
very pleased with that budget date today
because there's money for 185 000
affordable houses and a lot of those
will be in red wall seats well yes and i
think i've mentioned the guardian i
don't know if we've got to see it on
screen there and sunac's post covered
plan spend now cut taxes later let's
also take in the ft as well shall we at
kevin as soon as johnson on spending
referring to what andrew was talking
about just there but what about the task
he had in hand a lot of people were
saying he's got to tackle the cost of
living crisis going into this budget
given that a lot of households are
feeling very squeezed by rising
inflation increasing energy costs um as
well as other the the removal of the
uplift on universal credit lots of lots
of um issues to deal with to what extent
did he tackle that
i think very little actually he did
something such as he cancelled the
the alcohol duty uh hike but remember
he's putting up national insurance he is
freezing income tax thresholds he took
away six billion on uh universal credit
now he is cutting the taper and that
should be welcomed or going down from 63
to 55
percent the problems with tapers
problems were mean testing didn't come
in in 2010 when the conservatives came
back to power they've been around and
labor wrestled with this there's two now
that cut will help those people on
universal credit who are in work means
they'll have a bit more money to pay
their extra national insurance um but it
will still mean the marginal rate of tax
for someone who's a low earner is
effectively 55 percent that's a bit
higher once you put tax on income tax
national insurance i mean while for a
top earner the highest rate is 45. so
the system isn't isn't isn't fixed yet
but that was a move in the
in the right direction but the
i think the ft correctly do get it that
the
caster back um johnson on spending i
think um there are genuine tensions
between the two i think uh andrew's um
playing it down a bit uh now it may not
be as bad as it was in the summer when
the prime minister was uh was
remarking that he might sack the
chancellor in moving somewhere else down
in the street were briefing that was a
was a joke but nevertheless there was uh
a hint of the genuine irritation um in
it um the guardian uh which we which
we've seen i know i'm around here they
pick up on sunac saying he wasn't going
to mince words going forward every
marginal pound will be on lowering taxes
rather than extra spending so you can
see before the next general election
whether it's 24 23 or
even next year there will be some
announcement on lowering taxes to try
and wrong foots earth labor although
gordon brown has got to be recalled he
did cut income tax he also cuts
corporation tax which is going up from
19 to 25 percent okay under this
government quite rightly as well and
let's bring in the eye as well andrew at
their headline big spender sunak um
takes tax burden back to the 1950s and
and as they always do they have a series
of subheads as well one of them focuses
on this universal credit
issue
they say universal credit cards for
low-income families are scaled back but
rising inflation is forecast to wipe out
projected wage increases next year
pretty much reflecting what kevin was
saying i mean to what extent is this
going to matter a few months down the
line if people still feel badly off
well and
we don't yet know where this fuel crisis
is going to when we don't know how much
higher price is going to continue to
rise or not
look the the move on the taper on
universal credit was the the rabbit out
the hat nobody saw that coming nobody
expected that this has been a budget
that's had so many leaks i don't
remember a budget which literally quite
so much which is why the chancellor was
rebuked by the deputy speaker day
melanie lang today uh so but he's moved
on on the taper and that's going to save
families who are working are in receipt
of universal credit a thousand pounds a
year but if you're not working it's not
going to save you any money at all so uh
we are in for a cost of living crunch
but we are coming out of a pandemic and
it it we can't just go straight from uh
from from from where we've had millions
of people on furlough into into a a into
a position of of relative economic calm
we've got a long way to go we're in huge
debt and unfortunately there's always
people who are going to lose out on that
and it's going to be a tough tough year
if he keeps inflation down to around 4
i think they can probably get away with
it but some people think those inflation
projections are a bit too optimistic and
inflation could be going above five
percent even to six yeah that's right
that's right and we also take a break
but i'm just going to show the daily
star because i don't think we've seen
that um headline there i don't know if
you've seen it have you you two the
hangover part four they have and i can
that's obviously rishi sunak on the left
it's boris johnson in the middle do you
know who the one on the right is
i don't anyway it answers on a postcard
no anyway it says shortage of bills
soaring
simon clark i don't know oh it could be
it could be okay anyway
they're saying shortages a bill soaring
but don't fret bozo and rishi cutting
beer by o3p
that's uh that's their headline there
lots more to talk about don't go
anywhere but we are going to take a
break right now coming up getting ink on
their faces and in the papers insulate
britain are back and we'll be discussing
that next
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me tonight andrew pierce
and kevin mcguire and we're going to
turn to a couple of non-budget stories
if we can inside the metro
andrew and they're saying it's insulate
britain road mob sprayed with ink
presumably
good good and i hope it stains their
clothes permanently i hope it gets in
their eyes insulate britain are an
appalling bunch of uh
activists they've got this protest
completely wrong the sympathy that
people have for the noble objectives of
reducing climate change and carbon
emissions they've they've sacrificed so
much good will with their kamikaze
tactics stopping people getting to work
starting people on zero contracts zero
hour contracts getting to work stopping
people getting to hospital that poor
woman who was suffered a major paralysis
down one side she had a stroke because
she was stuck on the motorway for six
hours people have had enough of insulate
britain they're breaking all these
injunctions they now that so people have
struck back and sprayed that pain i
think what we really would like the next
time they glue their face to a road flip
and leave them there just leave them
there for a week but they soon kill kill
their arms
they're saying aren't they i'll put this
to kevin so you get a chance to have
your say kevin but they would say uh
this is a really important issue facing
our planet and humanity and if we're a
bit irritating sorry about that but at
least everyone's starting to talk about
it what do you think kevin no but we
don't need them to help us talk about in
climate change sky news do a climate
change program every night for half an
hour i've heard it's very good people
yeah people and you present it anna you
do it so well and people have been
talking about climate change for a very
long time this government has gotten
[Music]
thank you
now you you say that to greta thundberg
who you always uh sluggish he's
irritating as well
there we are there we are you're having
a real real big support for changing the
environment but anybody who advocated
you're against now i think that i think
they their hearts are in the right place
but they're
heads on even when they're glued well
particularly when they're glued to the
road because they are irritating people
and people aren't talking about the
issue that they're talking about these
people who are going around disrupting
their lives and people are people are
hitting back that's what's happened with
the ink in dartford we've seen people
manhandling them and i understand the
frustration of people who are trapped
and it's not it's not really about
insulate britain it's not about
insulating houses anymore it's about
these people causing disruption and
thankfully i don't think they've
undermined public opinion for the need
to tackle climate change they haven't
improved it or increased it but they
haven't undermined it because i think
most people can see that it's absolutely
crucially important that we stop the
earth
heating up and causing incredibly wild
swings in in the weather and and
threatening the the existence of many
species including our including
ourselves but
if i was insulin britain what they've
done it how many days is it now 15 days
of it don't they see maybe they like it
maybe the center of attention we're
talking about it when they're on tv and
they get off on that but they're not
doing their calls any good in fact
okay can i just say on this just briefly
you if you talk to climate change these
insulate britain spokes and say how much
will it cost to insulate every home in
britain as you want they don't have a
clue